Treasury Secretary Stephen minuchin
who's a member of the president's
coronavirus task force mrs. secretary
president Trump talked openly yesterday
about a possible quarantine of the New
York State area why did he first
consider it and why in the end did he
decide not to go ahead with it well of
course it's great to be back with you
the president did very seriously
consider it the task force met yesterday
with the vice president
it was the unanimous decision of the
Tekamah nation of the task force to go
forward with the Advisory the vice
president myself mark meadows and others
met with the president yesterday
afternoon and he decided to go forward
with the recommendation what was it that
made him think of quarantine might be
necessary and again why did he decide
not to do Chris I think the president
wanted to consider all the options he
was obviously concerned what was going
on with New York he spoke to the task
force he spoke to the governor's and he
was comfortable that people would take
this advisory very seriously and and
would not travel the coronavirus task
force of which you're a member is
meeting this weekend to come up with new
guidelines after the 15 days how to stop
the spread of the virus guidelines end
tomorrow here's what the president said
this week about what he'd like to see I
would love to have the country opened up
and just raring to go by Easter
as Treasury secretary do you think
that's realistic to open up parts of the
country to open up parts of the economy
as soon as two weeks from today which is
ease which will be easier Chris I'm
gonna leave that decision to the medical
professionals and the president my
full-time focus right now is we couldn't
be more pleased that the Senate and
House reacted very quickly signed an
enormous package to support us workers
in the US economy the President signed
it into law and my full-time focus is
delivering on that and let me just say
the the SBA is working very closely with
the Treasury we expect to have a program
up on Friday that will be up and running
that will cover half of the private
workforce I encourage all small
businesses to take out these loans
because if you go and hire back your
workers for eight weeks you will have a
forgivable loan and the government will
pay for that so again it is very
important for us that workers are
protected and this is a major part of
the package mrs. secretary I'm going to
get to that package in a moment but I
want to press on this issue of perhaps
changing the guidelines because that not
only has a lot of health implications it
also has a lot of economic implications
there's been a lot of pushback from
public health experts about the idea of
reopening parts of the country where
there's a lower incidence of the virus
opening them up with perhaps within two
weeks our very next guest dr. Tom
Ingoldsby
head of the Johns Hopkins Center for
Health security says this disease will
not respect state borders and city
borders and will move around this
country just like it's moved around the
world so the question is if the virus
spread from China to Italy can't it
spread from Chicago to Iowa and if we
were to open reopen parts of the country
too soon wouldn't that be the worst
thing for the economy if we see the
virus spreading into more areas Chris I
can assure you the president's
number-one objective is the health of
the American public in protecting the
American
public and we're going to do everything
to support the economy the task force
will be reviewing it it will be
discussing it with the president there
hasn't been any recommendation made yet
so again let me just emphasize the
president wants to make sure that we
kill this virus and we do it quickly and
the medical professionals are working on
that and while we do that we have now a
gigantic economic program to support
American workers in American business
yeah and let's get to that you were the
key administration a figure negotiating
that two trillion dollar
some call it relief bill some call it a
stimulus bill one part of that is five
hundred billion dollars a half a
trillion dollars to help dealing with
various big corporations how much
discretion do you and the president have
in deciding who to give that five
hundred billion dollars to which
corporations and under what terms Chris
there's two parts to this program
there's there's approximately fifty
billion dollars that we can make direct
Treasury loans that are subject to the
president in my approval those are
specifically designed for the airline
business and for the cargo business
which are national security concerns and
also give us flexibility if there are
other national security companies and
let me be clear tax payers will be fully
compensated for those loans the other
part of the package is for us to work
with the Federal Reserve I think you
know chairman Jay Powell and I now speak
multiple times a day on a regular basis
the 13-3 was a package that existed
under the Federal Reserve Act the
Federal Reserve has the ability to make
broad-based lending programs available
once the Fed requests that those actions
they come to me I have to approve them
his Treasury secretary and in many cases
I contribute capital to support that in
consultation with the president so these
are very important programs we think
they can provide about four trillion
dollars of liquidity to the American
economy again we expect we will get paid
back on these loans these are temporary
support for
American economy that's very very very
critical and we've already rolled out
many of these already but mr. secretary
one of the big sticking points when you
were negotiating with Democrats in the
Senate is they wanted an Inspector
General to oversee the big loans the big
grants to big corporations in just two
hours after the President signed the two
trillion dollar bill he put out
assigning the statement saying that he
will only allow that Inspector General
to report to Congress under quote
presidential supervision so didn't that
basically violate the deal you made with
the Democrats in the Senate I don't
think that's the case Chris there's
constitutional issues again we're gonna
have full transparency the way this
works is we have full transparency and
reporting what we're doing to the
American public we also have a partisan
Oversight Committee that will review our
actions we are fully comfortable that
whatever we do we want full transparency
and we're very careful in what we're
doing about supporting American workers
in the American economy so directly will
the Inspector General that was provided
for in this bill be allowed to testify
and report to Congress Chris I'm gonna
leave that to the lawyers okay and to
Congress to figure out my full-time
objective right now is to make sure this
administration does everything we can to
get this money into the economy quickly
that's a combination of small business
loans that will be available this week
and let me just be clear this is not
just normal SBA lenders any FDIC bank
any credit union any FinTech lender will
be authorized to make these loans
subject certain approvals will also have
direct deposit into people's accounts
within three weeks so they have checks
these are bridge checks we have enhanced
unemployment insurance that we're
working with the states this is all
about the president's determination to
support the US economy
finally mr. secretary 3.3 million people
applied for unemployment benefits this
week that is four times the previous
highest record in the since 1967 when
these records were kept former head of
the CBO says that we're going to see an
unemployment rate in the next few months
of 20 percent your former company
goldman sachs is projecting that GDP in
the second quarter instead of being up 2
percent or 3 percent is going to be
minus 24 percent is that what you're
seeing at the Treasury Department 20
percent unemployment a GDP shrinking
from year over year by a quarter Chris
it's it's hard to predict these numbers
because we've never had anything like
this where we've shut down the US
economy for medical reasons the economy
was in very very good health and we shut
it down and let me just say we're very
sympathetic to the people who who don't
have jobs and that's why the president
was very clear that he wanted me to work
with Congress on a bipartisan basis
quickly to support those people so I
hope number-one businesses rehire small
businesses rehire those people now that
they'll have the money number two people
will have enhanced unemployment
insurance in number three people have
direct deposit money in their accounts
to provide liquidity and we want to get
people back to work as quickly as we can
subject to the medical conditions
understood but briefly I've got about 30
seconds left you're saying you seem to
be saying the 20% unemployment and GDP -
a quarter twenty four percent is not
impossible may not be may not last long
but we may see those numbers we may have
to live with that Chris I don't know
what the numbers are gonna be this
quarter what I do think is we are going
to kill this virus we're gonna reopen
this economy and in the third quarter of
this year you're gonna see this economy
bounce back with very large GDP numbers
and low unemployment back to where we
were beforehand so the president has
determined that we protect people and
reopen the economy when it's the right
time
secretary minuchin thank you thanks for
your time during these busy days always
good to talk with you sir thank you
Chris